now all you've got to do is call
that's adrian houghton and tamara mowry
housley
coming together for the first time in a
year i don't even know where to begin
their reunion was great but the comment
section is what got people talking yup
your eyes are not deceiving you
that's tamera and her former real
co-host tamar braxton
writing each other on instagram showing
there's no bad blood between the ladies
the girls will always be a part of my
family but
let's rewind on wednesday adrienne
shared a series of photos on vacation in
upstate new york where she had the
chance to reconnect with her longtime
girlfriend
posting this emotional video
[Music]
adrian captioned it going from seeing
you every day to not seeing you for a
whole year
wow i missed your face turns out the
former cheetah girl wasn't the only one
missing tamara
as tamar commented these three emojis on
the video
you know i have changed i am shade free
now i went to shade anonymous
tamera who left the reel in july 2020
replied to tamar's comment by writing
hi taytay i miss you along with a sad
emoji face
i'm just really glad that everybody's in
a better place hours after the senior
responded
i miss you too and so much i support the
girls
still individually tamar was one of the
original co-hosts of the reel along with
tamara
adrian jeannie mai and lonnie love but
the singer had a falling out with the
ladies in 2016
after she was fired from the show
following her departure tamar accused
the four women of playing a role in her
exit
which they denied she also unfollowed
lonnie on instagram
prompting fans to believe the comedian
had something to do with it
which she denied at the time and again
to et last year while promoting her
memoir
i've tried to to contact her and
and and actually have her come on and
talk and
then it's so much this happening so
it's just you know you feel bad and all
you can do like i said
at a certain point in your life you go
you know what
i just gotta say my side of the story no
matter how late it is
i have to say my side of the story and
then
from that you know the you leave a
door open and that's it but
you know like i said i wish this was
done totally different
because none of the girls should have
been blamed none of us did anything
while lonnie says she's never received
an explanation for tamar's exit
she wishes her nothing but the best i
just wish her the best i think she's a
powerhouse i think she's
you know no matter what you know
things happen but it's just time to just
really get together and she knows that
we're not
we're not mad at her we're not upset
it's just that we just want
you know we want to clear the record
seems like this friendly instagram
exchange is a great place to start
[Music]
you